ea nous allons maintenant recevoir
charles du mouchard le démon qui a écrit
de nombreux succès pour edith piaf dont
on célèbre aujourd'hui le 20e
anniversaire de sa mort le 11 octobre
1963 c'était exactement le même jour que
jean cocteau qui disait d'elle est dit
est une est un oiseau et sa voix
troublera le monde durant des siècles
est ce que vous partagez cet avis qui
est un petit peu qui donne une dimension
épique à ce héros populaire oui c'est
beaucoup plus qu'ailleurs aux populaires
c'est beaucoup plus qu'une chante c'est
devenu un mythe
pierre de passe de personnes extraction
ne pas ce qu'elle a réussi à faire de sa
vie était devenue un personnage
légendaire savais que je crois que en
france ne vont pas beaucoup de
personnages légendaires qui
appartiennent en tout cas aux métiers de
la chanson les américaines dont marilyn
monroe james dean
nous en france même parmi les comédiens
on n'a pas beaucoup de gens là à
l'internât entendu par l'auto feldman
sarah bernhardt mais qui malheureusement
n'a pas laissé de l'iran philippe quand
même oui mais pas comme impact de la
route de la pierre je vous dis
aujourd'hui votre pierre je suis allé à
moscou ont joué à moscou une pièce de
kinki répondu la vie de piaf le chalet
allons jouer à londres une pièce qui a
raconté la vie de pierre
je suis allé aux états unis on rentre je
veux une pièce qui raconte la vie de
madame pierre c'est quelque chose
d'unique dans l'abandon dans l'univers
de la chanson se dit madame piaf comme
certains comédiens qui avait travaillé
avec pierre fresnay 10eme su freiner
c'est une forme de rester oui bien sûr
on ne peut pas parler des gens de cette
dimension à savoir un profond respect
vous savez je dis d'ailleurs une
journaliste
on a raconté sur un nid de piaf le pire
et le meilleur l'a dit des sottises
vérité mais en fait le public ne s'y est
pas trompé parce que qu'est-ce qui vous
intéresse le physique ce qui intéresse
le public c'est ce que faisait un bien
c'est quand on écoute chanter parce qu
en fait qu'est ce qui est important pour
un artiste c'est ce qu'il fait quand il
le fait et a qu'à mettre un disque de
piaf sur une platine ouvrir les oreilles
et le miracle s'accomplit c'est ça le
jeu de ma fille candy langlois et pensez
vous de la profusion de livres qui ont
été écrits soit par des amis swaps soit
disant par elle des confessions ou alors
ce tout dernier par exemple edith piaf
l'amour toujours par andré larue qui
cite ces hommes et dans lequel vous
exciter les équipes et je crois que
c'est tant mieux
le savait on disait qu une grande
communion avis l'essentiel c'est qu'on
en parle
bon alors qu n'ont pas le temps de mieux
que l'on parle parce que chacun y
retrouvera pour un prochain empêcher qui
est des gens méchants étaient des gens
gentils quai des imbéciles et
intelligent alors à chacun de choisir
dans le créneau ce qu'il paraît être le
meilleur de s'informer avant de lire les
mauvaises choses retomberont la poubelle
et les bonnes choses ne font que rendre
hommage à cette grande île merveilleuse
extraordinaire chanteuse qui a été dit
alors vous vous avez publié un album sur
des pièces mais ça n'est pas un album
souvenir c'est un agent que je fais donc
un vide dans lequel selon on disait des
dj les champs tellement bien qu'elle
projetait le bota alors c'était à la
fois gentil à la fois méchant ça voulait
dire quelque part que c'était seulement
sa voix qu'on écoute et et que ce
qu'elle disait savez aucune somme
importance j'ai voulu vingt ans après
reprendre des chansons que j'avais
composé pour elle mange la taille 1 mon
dieu la ville inconnue et c est une
nouvelle chanson qui s'appelait
souviens-toi des flonflons qui est une
poisse technique n'obtenait pas le temps
d'en parler si tout mais je crois que
c'est important de dire comment vous
avez fait pour mettre en terre et aux
labos de caftans il est à prévoir que
chacun rendre autonome âgées c'est très
bien je vous remercie en n2
radio qui font un hommage à piaf elle a
beaucoup donné c'est normal qu'on s'en
souvienne
donc c'est très heureux d'assister à
cette émission
mais ce cet hommage était prévisible à
vingt ans après alors il m'a semblé que
serré le plus important pour lui rendre
hommage c'était la faire chanter alors
avec lui jean claude petit qui est un
merveilleux musicien arrangeur de 2,30 à
l'anarchie l'orchestration sur une
chanson chantée et dit qu'il s'appelait
les fonds fournis balle on a refilé en
question de la première note à la
dernière note dans ce sur ce canevas
j'ai composé une nouvelle chanson que
certains souviens-toi des champions qui
est un hommage à édith et ça nous a
permis comme c'est sur le même canevas
sur la même prestation dans le temps de
prendre la voix d'edith piaf au départ
de chanter ma chanson qui est un hommage
à édith et de reprendre la voie dès 10
heures pour terminer et je crois que
c'est ça qui était important je crois
que je le répète ce qui est important
pour madame biya sait l'écouter chanter
bien nous allons vous écouter charles
dumont dans cette chanson que vous avez
réaménagé donc comme vous venez de nous
l'expliquer
et
non non sous
il ya tant de gens
le
français
rue où l'on veut
la musique
tout en bois des pins
il ya peu
on est
en dessous il y a
aubin
trois fois rien
mais ressort
plein
or
oh
la ville était
il y a
monde
le nord
une chanson pour le
c'est bon
bah
mais la peur
une histoire d'hommes
de paris
non
oui
charles dumont hommage à edith piaf sur
des paroles de sophie makhno